hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Emily wants to play
now I got some lovely advice by a person
by the name of Ivan to kick hello
everybody
that told me basically in the
instructions that I need to face all
these horrible monstrosity z' that are
in this game so with this advice I'm
probably still gonna lose fail miserably
cry in a corner and then hug myself as I
slowly drift off into insanity something
like that I have no idea but let's
continue to play the game and hopefully
if none of that happens I'll actually
succeed but frankly I don't even know
how to tell what time it is when I'm
playing this game so I'm just going to
kinda wander around and be a big jump do
fee do so I can only assume that I'm
supposed to go until 6 a.m. which is
usually what these types of games are
want to do
and with that being said I don't exactly
know how I'm sure she'll be able to tell
the time because that clock over there
doesn't seem to move at all but speaking
of moving so what I need to do there's
three or four if you can't Emily
different here so what the hell is this
look at these no books are these like a
makeshift table because for some reason
the dining room didn't exactly work also
I did I never really noticed but these
people must just be moving in or either
they're packing up in a hurry and trying
to get the hell out of here be the way
that has nothing to do with I'm trying
to do here so they said that the
whiteboard actually is trying to lead
you astray obviously don't look at her
winky face I've never seen sassy
monsters in a game before but here they
be so they're trying to trick poor
little me here and you're supposed to
stare at her until she goes away because
my mistake was who's trying to run away
as fast as I could
Oh God who did that hi We're day okay
I'm supposed to stare at your creepy
little ass until you run away so spook
on out here I've been lifting weights
and by weights I mean I've been lifting
my big flabby body up a wall so you
don't want to know the kind of pain
disappointing was that a laugh I heard I
have no goddamn idea okay
they lock me up down there okay cool who
did that
who's slumping who's flopping oh I know
my glasses are messed up I'm just gonna
leave it as an element of my own change
what was that talking about this game
being spooky I don't know
anyway all right moving on back to
seriousness so what I need to do thank
you
I wonder who the hell is doing that
because I know this house is filled with
sassy goats where Oh seemed exactly
natural for you just to be hanging on
the windowsill over there frankly I'm
not gonna question things I'm not gonna
try to threaten you because somehow you
made me hit myself in my own eyeball and
it hurt it still hurts but frankly I'm
gonna choke back my tears did I mention
that after I play this I'm gonna be in a
corner weeping like a baby and then
crying myself to sleep cuz it's kind of
my plans for the night Oh God oh so I
got a run around this house rampage you
trying to keep all the lights on with
these little scampers clock move your
[ __ ] [ __ ] get off the block clock put on
some socks clock oh man get a new door
okay that hasn't changed
I wonder if anything has actually
changed I mean what am I supposed to do
why am i wandering around someone else's
house just meandering back and forth
until I survive hey how's it going lady
or girl weirdo weirdo I'm gonna go with
weirdo yeah so I guess I guess we could
be friends you know I don't know how
close I can get to you I'm just gonna
try to keep my distance at this point
but uh if the main person is named Emily
no I think actually Ivan to kick told me
that this one is named Kiko oh there she
goes
there goes Kiko and then the other one
is like mr. er mr. huggles and then
huncles I think the last ones name is
Chung khals mr. huggles and Chung khals
they have distinctive laughs and I'm
supposed to do other stuff with them I
don't exactly remember what I was
supposed to do that's probably important
for my
survival but at this point I'm just
gonna try to worry about Kiku and then
do nothing what the hell happened there
it isn't open Oh Oh God
don't sneak up on me like that
I was probably pretty close to death and
the other one like the clown you're
supposed to stand completely still and
not move and then Chung khals you're
supposed to run away as fast as you can
I don't know when they're gonna show up
and either Oh Frick is not okay because
I don't want to just be wandering around
and then eventually have to deal with
the other ones because it's going to be
a long ass game if I'm if I have to
struggle through hours of failure just
to be able to progress a little bit in
this game thank you right where are you
where are you where are you where are
you honest here I don't see her I don't
see her where is he [ __ ] yes I was born
this but I'll punch you in the darkness
oh god I think she's over there
somewhere
she's gotta be right oh god if guy I
haven't got a bead on her she must be
over there she's got to be better not
turn off the light in this room I'm like
a word
oh how this does that I'm gonna die
Oh No is this where huggles comes by
hello
Kiko mr. cloudy boo oh boy oh boy I
think when the clown laughs I'm supposed
to not move like at all I have a funny
feeling I'm gonna be moving when he
laughs okay maybe if I just stand still
it'll be totally fun I guess you know
near here right yeah good old light
switch and nothing can possibly bad
happen god damn it again the whole stop
okay so you're still here oh so still
you huh huh [ __ ] me hi how's it going
how are you doing huh don't move
okay little bit but it was like a twitch
god damn it you goddamn clown [ __ ] what
the hell was that all about
oh my god my heart not okay okay so I
moved a little it was like instinctual I
was like don't move and then I twitched
and moved like an idiot so I'm gonna go
cry myself to sleep in a corner I'm
gonna take a lovely hot bath and then be
scared for the rest of the night so
thank you everybody so much for watching
so I'm gonna progress through this very
very slowly Lucas I'm terrible at it but
I'll try to combine some nights and
later episodes once I'm better than this
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see
in the next video